انت كيف ترى التداعيات المحتمله على هذا
التحالف الطاوله السداسيه خاصه اذا ما
استطاعت فعلا ان تذهب الى جوله ثانيه في
مواجهه الرئيس رجب طيب اردو ان الذي بدا
واثقا بخطابه خطاب الشرفه في مركز العداله
والتنميه وقال بانه يعتقد بانه قادر على
خدمه
تركيا لولايه ثانيه ولكن اذا كان الامر
يحتاج الى جوله ثانيه فهو مستعد طبعا يعني
انا يعني لا ارى يعني بالنسبه للجوله
الثانيه حظ للمعارضه بعد هذا الفجل خاصه
في نتائج البرلمان
وايضا لا ارى المستقبل بالنسبه
للطابله سداسيه بعد يعني بعد هذا اليوم
بعد اسبوعين نستطيع ان نقول
ايضا يعني حياه
السياسي بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
واعتقد تنتهي بعدها يعني عمره 74 طبعا
هناك 20 سنه لم يفوز حتى الان الا
الانتخابات البلديات ضد حزب العداله
والتنميه
وستكون هناك منافسه شرسه بالنسبه
للرئاسه حزب الجمهور الشعبي وايضا من نسبه
لعضو
الطاوله السداسيه يعني
الاحزاب الصغرى
وطبعا
يعني استطيع ان نقول
المولود الميت نوعا ما لان اول
الانتخابات ومع حزب الشعب حزب الجمهور
الشعبي يعني ما استطيع ان يكون هناك فوز
وانا ارى تغيير كبير جدا في المنظر
السياسي التركي خاصه من قبل من طرف
المعارضه سواء حزب
الجمهوري الشاب وايضا
الاحزاب الاخرى يعني
لا ارى ان يكون هناك حظ بالنسبه لهم من
نسبه المستقبل
وطبعا الشيء المهم سنان اوغان سيكون في
المستقبل السياسي التركيه لانه بدون اي
حزب هو اخذ اكثر من خمسه هذا الشيء 5.25
حتى اكثر من مليون مليونين مليونين ونصف
هذا شيء كبير جدا بدون يعني اي حزب ان
يستطيع ان ياخذ هذا هذا بالنسبه لمستقبل
السياسه التركيه وايضا ارى ممكن
المنافسه بين محرم انجا
امام موضوع
لرئاسته الجمهور الشعبي من رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول بالنسبه للمستقبل يعني سيكون
تغيير كبير جدا
بعد هذه الفتره وسارى الشباب سياتون اكثر
بالنسبه للسياسه كان الواحد وعشرين في
تركيا